so look just like in business or in life
you're one person away one recruit away
either you're life-changing or your
company changing in intermiami this is a
soccer team that was worth 500 million
dollars just a year ago today they're
guesstimating that the organization is
now worth one and a half billion dollars
after recruiting one guy named Messi
June 7th enter Miami's Instagram account
had 900 000 followers today two and a
half months later it went from 900 000
to 14.3 million and they just won the
champ they went from the worst to the
best couple other people showed up Messi
got 50 60 million a year plus bonuses
plus possible Equity when he's done
retirement playing with these guys after
two and a half years eventually his
career earnings are going to be around
1.6 billion dollars so what can you and
I learn as a business owner myself I
made seven eight nine points how this
applies to all of us how you are one
recruit away from taking your life and
your business to the next level
thank you all right so if you get value
out of this video give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel now for
those of you that know who Messi is he's
the goat he's just one with Argentina
there's no more argument it's a done
done the guys won seven ballon d'ores
won the Champions League four times in
the Copa America with Argentina he
scored 815 goals for the club and the
country throughout his professional
career I can go on and on the first and
only player in the history to win five
and six European golden boots he holds
the record for the most goals in La Liga
with 474 the player with the most
official recorded assistant football
history with 357 and he's the only
player to have 300 Club career assist to
his name so having said that what are
the points that we have when it comes
out to business I got Market synergist
Vision proven concept plant the seed
sell the dream and follow-up challenge
accepted so let's go through the market
first of all to attract somebody as good
as messy to your company you got to have
these eight things in place number one a
market what is the market Miami Gustavo
starlinkov the man who introduced Messi
to his first Miami home sold messy unit
at Porsche Design Tower in Sunny Isles
Beach in 29 19 it was the star's First
South Florida property he bought at the
time it was a 5 million dollar deal
handling both sides of transaction for a
4 400 square foot unit on the 47th floor
of the 60-story luxury Oceanfront Tower
beautiful property so comes in looks at
the place while I'm kind of like in
Miami he's seen the market he's excited
about it since then Messi has invested
heavily into Miami no wonder he's
considering a two and a half year
contract so he's coming to Miami he's
liking the market he's liking what it's
looking like and then all of a sudden he
sees you know Market Miami is doing
their part Dana White comes out and says
in an interview oh Miami just broke the
record for the biggest gate for UFC 281
beating out Madison Square Garden he's
given all these numbers 11 and a half
million it was the same as the main
event and
Miami is what La was 10 years ago so the
market is ripe to recruit somebody like
that so look one of the things that
happens when you're running a business
and you got a big Vision many times
you're going to be alone you don't have
somebody to talk you want to go to your
wife you can't talk to your wife you
want to go to your family they're like
nobody told you to start a business or
anything big you're trying to do with
your life there's going to be moments
where you're going to be by yourself and
you're afraid to go talk to somebody
maybe your therapist don't use that word
to go see a therapist guess what I did
many times when I was starting my
business I don't know anybody to talk to
sometimes you go to in a place and
you're sitting down and you're like wait
a minute A co-worker is like what are
you doing here there's a company called
better help where you get to go and talk
to a therapist on your phone you can
have the camera on if you want to and if
you don't want to have the camera on you
don't want to no problem you can do it
on audio to speak to somebody if it
doesn't work out you'll change it up
better help offers 30 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues to get
started all you have to do is answer a
few questions about your needs and
preferences in therapy that way better
health can match you better with the
right therapist from their Network then
you can talk to your therapist however
you feel comfortable whether it's via
text chat phone or video call and you
can message your therapist at any time
and schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you get 10 off your first
month's order if you go to
betterhelp.com forward slash
valuetainment and I've also linked them
below as well again go to betterhelp.com
forward slash valuetainment or click on
the link below and you get 10 off your
first month number two you need a
synergist a synergist is Beckham on
February 5th of 2014 MLS announced that
Beckham had exercised his option to buy
MLS expansion team for 25 million
dollars which he had received as part of
the contract he signed with the LA
Galaxy in 2007. the ownership group led
by Beckham originally hoped the
miami-based team would begin play in
2016-2017 after delays in getting a
stadium deal completed MLS announced in
January of 2018 that the team had been
approved and will likely begin play in
2020. so Beckham the center just like
look this place is great you may want to
come here what if we do something
together you should come take a look at
us so Beckham's kind of doing his part
as a synergist telling him I said yeah
you ought to come to MLS I know we're
like better than this but trust me we
can make this work we can be heroes and
Americans Messi is thinking about it
okay so now we have the market and we
have the synergist which is kind of like
Beckham he relates to Beckham Beckham
was one of the best players to ever play
you're willing to go to MLS and LA
Galaxy maybe I ought to considered this
but then it was somebody that was
planning to see it and that's Jorge Mas
the owner in 2019 inner Miami started
talking about getting messy I think
think he comes with a desire to leave
his Mark and he will be able to do so
beyond football when he retires he will
have a stake in the club I imagine a
life after football for Messi very
similar to David Beckham or Michael
Jordan he's recruiting now hey you may
want to come to and this is 2019. think
about from 2019 four years ago until
June 7th of 2023 after he wins the World
Cup you're willing to get a guy like
that to come to you you got to respect
Jorge Mas they also discussed
surrounding Messi with players of his
level so at the same time while they're
talking to Messi they're like look who
are these guys best friends who are your
Co who do you want to play with and they
knew Jordi Alba was one of his best
friends then they knew Sergio busquets
which is another teammate that he had in
the past and then a coach who he had
played with before from 2014 to 2016
Tata Martino and they said hey if you
come here what if we go get these guys
I'm just like we can't get them if you
get him I'd be interested again this
whole thing is the offer being put
together and planting the seed
eventually that little vision became a
reality so now you have to realize while
this has happened happening Saudi Arabia
is offering this guy 400 million dollars
come and play with us oh my gosh this
guy's going to go over there and play
but does he really want to go over there
someone is selling him the dream this
entire time and it's not one person it's
not two it's the collective group now
celebrities from Miami are selling them
the dream you should come here this is
the place to be this is the place where
your kids can be raised a lot of
like-minded people they'll love you and
hear you know you're from Argentina he
wanted to get the love it wasn't just
about money from there's some players
that when they get to a point to retire
the only thing that matters to them is
I'm old let me get my money messy it was
much more than money for him he wanted
to be the greatest of all time a win for
his country he did a check number two he
wanted to be in a place to raise his
family around people that he's loved and
he's accepted and that dream was sold
properly to him by everybody in Miami so
so a guy like this needs a proven
concept to say well why would I do this
if there's a proven concept Remember The
Sinner just earlier David Beckham
massive role look at the relationship
and the bond between them he was the one
that was the first that took the risk 25
million dollars MLS who watched MLS back
in the days 15 years nobody now today
nobody would I remember I went and sat
down with the owner of Houston Dynamo he
picked up that Organization for 40
million dollars I've been to that game I
know the owner he was one of my
investors in the past with the company
with De La Hoya MLS no one believed it
but the proven concept and shown that
this is possible eventually got messy to
say I'm coming so imagine you're back on
this entire time you're like dude I'd
love to get messy I'd love to get messy
I'd love to get messy it's on him to
prove to the market that this is the
place to be the more he proved working
behind closed doors constantly
eventually he earned the right he had
the moral authority to say Messi come
take a look at this this could be a real
thing for you and eventually obviously
it happened and by the way the last one
I'll tell you this isn't just one person
or two people this was a lot of people
constantly following up hey have you
seen what happened here did you see what
Continental Miami did you see during
covet did you see what Florida did did
you see what's going on in Florida have
you seen the schools have you seen
what's going on here what about if you
come here they love you here it's
constant follow-up follow-up follow-up
follow-up follow-up until eventually he
came here let me tell you when I knew he
was moving to Miami I got an email one
day from his realtor hey Patrick
Messi really likes your house he saw
your video he saw the house he wants to
come in toward a house and this is the
amount it was a very friendly generous
monthly amount do you realize when I had
to send that email back my nine-year-old
was so upset at me that I didn't say yes
my nine-year-old was saying we'll share
the house with him I said buddy this
guy's not sharing a house with us and we
can't we got a lot of stuff going on we
have to say thank you appreciate the
fact that you like the house but we
cannot do it that's when I knew he was
coming here because we got that email he
came to our community he looked at the
houses craziness and by the way I sent a
couple of our guys to go watch his game
in Argentina when they won the finals
with mbappe France when mbappe had three
goals and they come back just to
craziness that sporting event the game
may go down as the most incredible
sporting game of any sport of all time
Messi was a part of it because he
carried so much of a burden because if
he didn't win that day he can't go down
as the greatest of all time because he
doesn't have a World Cup and he pulled
it off so for Miami to have picked up a
guy like him Jose seems like a Family
Guy a loving guy a guy that matches the
audience that's here in South Florida
Florida loves him he loves Florida it's
been such a great partnership him
winning the championship he takes the
captain off he gives it to the older
captain and he says no let's lift it up
together you ought to do it because you
were the captain before me the greatest
of all time to do that it's the kind of
stuff that you look at he said there's a
reason why this guy's a builder he's a
leader amongst leaders you gotta love
messy on what he's done so when you get
a chance to recruit a guy like Messi
within your business you may not get him
right off the bat it may take you six
months 12 months 24 months may take you
three five sometimes may even take you
ten years like they did with Beckham but
if you do pick him up that team that
Beckham bought for 25 million dollars is
not today worth about a billion and a
half one guy took the valuation from 500
million to a billion and a half so if
you got those guys you want to recruit
be patient with them you recruit them
life-changing and also your business is
going to change if you got value out of
this video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel and if you're wondering
why so many guys are looking at sports I
just became recently a minority owner of
the Yankees why are people is
alternative Investments and sports teams
and aren't something you ought to look
at you may want to click here to watch
that video because some of the data is
absolutely crazy with what country in
the world is so interested in sports in
America take care everybody
foreign